can Memorex shatter the glass in the
1970s technology tried to duplicate The
Genius of Ella Fitzgerald's voice is it
live or is it Memorex too often we have
seen what happens when technology
outpaces regulation nearly 50 years
later a U.S senator convened a hearing
on artificial intelligence or did he the
words were not mine
and the audio was an AI voice cloning
software trained on my floor speeches
the remarks were written by chat gbt
when it was asked
how
I would open this hearing Max Headroom
at one point cartoon figures such as Max
Headroom and computer generated news
readers such as ananova were considered
more entertainment than threats to
society but after the spread of
misinformation and lies during the 2016
and 2020 presidential campaigns
president Trump won legislators are
afraid AI could be used to destroy faith
in government and other institutions The
Man Behind chat GPT the software which
fabricated Senator blumenthal's opening
remarks said the answer is government
regulation I would form a new agency
that licenses any effort above a certain
scale of capabilities and can take that
license away and ensure compliance with
safety standards number two I would
create a set of safety standards focused
on what you said in your third
hypothesis as the dangerous capability
evaluations while some in the tech
industry have their misgivings IBM urges
Congress to adopt a Precision regulation
approach to AI
this means establishing rules to govern
the deployment of AI and specific use
cases not regulating the technology
itself
others say congress isn't up to the job
of regulating at least not yet so I
think you know the tech industry we're
ready to come to Washington and help
write legislation but it's going to go
further than that right we need to
ensure that our politicians understand
this technology and currently most of
them do not understand technology a
recognition that ai's impact could be
much more than shattering glass for fun
Rosalind Jordan Al Jazeera Washington
Russia is threatening to pull